has a fantastic support network around  him  yeah the family great coaches as well  yeah Arjun still it's only going to be  half time after uh today yeah still  plenty of opportunity okay here the  white king comes the white apron drops  but we will see  okay  we did it blunder yeah well he kind of  blundered away the win  but uh is he losing no is it going to be  a draw probably  but uh I still win anyway  I think he's realized that once the  white king starts coming towards the  center it still looks winning to me oh  it still looked winning to me but once  the white king starts coming there will  be a way to kick it out to the middle of  the board  but uh yeah still zero risk and yeah the  wind's gone but the match what today's  one match will be over  white is just going to push his G Pawn  now  arjun's still on the defensive despite  clawing his way back somewhat